the feud between President Trump and Jim
Comey is turning into a ballistic
tit-for-tat on the airwaves Comey
defended himself by going on the attack
on CNN last night do you think that
there's any credence to the president's
claims that you broke the law when you
released your memos I don't hope that
won't surprise you I don't in fact I
think he's just making stuff up
President Trump returned fire in a phone
interview on Fox & Friends this morning
look Comey is a leaker and he's a liar
he leaked classified information in
order to try and get a special counsel
he also leaked the memos which are
classified he is guilty of crimes and if
we had a Justice Department that was
doing their job in his Fox News
interview with Bret Baier tonight Comey
responded to Trump's accusations he's
just wrong facts really do matter which
is why I'm on this show to answer your
questions that memo was unclassified
then it's still unclassified it's in my
book
the FBI cleared that book before it
could be published that's a false
statement let's separate fact from
fiction with our expert panel
Congressman Jim Jordan a member of the
House Judiciary Committee and the
oversight committees Fox News
contributor Byron York Washington
Examiner Richard Goodstein
a former adviser to President Clinton
all right congressman Jordan a lot to
unpack we got to get through it all I
want to play for you part of this
interview tonight where Brett asked
about the Clinton investigation in the
comparison let's watch you see the
disparity here where people look at how
the Clinton case was handled and how the
Trump case is handled did did you tell
what you don't see disparity there is a
disparity the American people see it the
president is not wrong he's not making
things up he's not making up the fact
that they called up Cheryl Mills and
said hey Cheryl what time can we come
over and you hand over the emails you
want us to have Mills was Clinton's
lawyer and her chief of staff for
goodness sake and subject of the
investigation when the Clinton
investigation started compare that to
the idea that the president's personal
lawyer gets his door kicked in and the
Attorney General the United States I
don't even think was consulted it was
run outside of the umbrella of the
Russian investigation the Moller Special
Counsel investigate
and you don't talk to the highest law
enforcement officer in the land when
you're kicking in the president's
lawyers door of course the president
should be upset by that kind of
treatment more importantly the American
people are upset Byron there was a
moment where they discussed who funded
the dossier I know you've been writing
about this let's watch when did you
learn that the DNC and Hillary Clinton
campaign had funded Christopher Steele's
work yeah I still don't know that for a
fact
what do you mean I've only seen it in
the media I never knew exactly which
Democrats had funded and it was funded
first by Republicans opposed to dollar
I'm sorry that's not sure that the
dossier that Christopher Steele worked
on was funded by Republican my
understanding was his work started
funded by Oppo Riaz Oppo research funded
by Republicans because you want to know
who was funded by I wanted to know what
I knew which is it was funded by people
politically opposed to Donald Trump
okay which particular opponents wasn't
that important
this was a stunning moment I mean he
showed apparent ignorant of the basic
facts of the dossier which has become
one of the most important documents I
think in the whole why because what was
the base of the main basis for the
application to spy on Carter press that
also that's also what Comey and the
other Intel Chiefs briefed
president-elect
Trump on on January 6 2017 starting the
whole fight between Trump and Comey
so it's it's a hugely important document
he also seemed to kind of repeat a left
wing talking point that it began with
Republicans and we know I think anybody
has followed it knows that the fusion
GPS research into Trump's business life
began with Republicans they quit that
and then the steel dossier was funded
all of it by Republican but you're on a
book tour you've sold like 600,000 books
which is amazing you wrote a book about
this and you're on Bret Baier show and
you're like trying to play oh oh I don't
know really if the Democrats what I read
in the media but the Republicans started
it I mean you just wrote a book about
this you were FBI director you use this
document Richard I'm sorry but that did
strike me as quite a
stunner if I can Congress made reference
to Cheryl Mills that Hillary Clinton's
lawyer Donald Trump who said famously on
Air Force one call my lawyer
Michael Cohen and famously said during
the campaign if you take the fifth it's
because you're guilty that's what mob
people do his lawyers taking the fifth
Cheryl Mills never took the fifth nobody
in the Clinton orbit took this other
than other than the one guy other than
the one guy should have to take the fish
got the immunity it gave her immunity
fine so they could they could have
anybody they wanted him you know why
would they give her I mean look the fact
of the matter is the suggestion that
there's somehow a comparison between the
two
Carter Paige was one of five foreign
policy advisors that Donald Trump named
and the FBI had reason to believe he was
a foreign agent excuse me that's nothing
like what we're talking about Donald
Trump went into the Oval Office and gave
Russians secrets about the Israelis
being embedded and ways in which the the
Islamic we're talking about the former
FBI director who is on this network
tonight who made comments that were I
mean a run-of-the-mill pundit on any
cable network would know the answers to
which I found unbelievable I want to
play another sound byte this is on the
FISA application itself and again Byron
you've been writing about this
congressman you've been dissecting this
let's watch I called the dossier
unverified salacious why did you use
that to the FISA Court to ask for
surveillance for Carter page not only
use it but you led with it a bulk of
that FISA application deals with that
dossier why yeah that's not my
recollection Brett and I don't know that
the FISA application has been released
my recollection was it was part of a
broader mosaic of facts that were laid
before the FISA judge to obtain a FISA
warrant it was a lot more than the
dossier in the FISA application my
recollection was there was a significant
amount of additional material about page
and why there was probable cause to
believe he was an agent of a foreign
power is that true no they led with it
when you lead with it that's your
primary evidence that you're taking -
have you seen the entire example we have
not but but - I have because they won't
let us I asked Christopher Rea under
oath will you show it to us you can
clear all this up well they won't show
it to us they
Wow they didn't tell the court two
things they didn't tell the court who
paid for it namely the Democrat natural
community Clinton campaign they didn't
tell the court that the author of the
document Christopher steel had his
relationship with the FBI terminated
they didn't tell the court that you when
we go to court we got to tell him the
whole truth not part of the truth the
whole truth they didn't do that remember
that house Intel found out that the
dossier was the bulk of it and
separately the Senate Judiciary
Committee also found that the right that
it was the bulk of it he also said he
didn't see any bias Richard in the page
struck text when page and struck talked
about the insurance policy they were you
know they were clearly not wild about
Donald Trump even that's even been said
on other networks but he didn't see any
bias well again there were Republicans
on this network and others who were
saying the same things about Donald
Trump during the 2016 campaign that
struck was struck with saying the same
things about burns again he was saying
the same thing about Bernie Sanders and
about Eric Holder and so forth I mean
the fact is they were they were dishing
dirt or trashing everybody they could so
to suggest that some I mean struck was
the person who suggested that Comey do
the letter that basically was the
beginning of the end for Hillary Clinton
so I don't think you really see if it
wasn't bias it was animus towards the
president and Peter struck is not just
any old person who was criticized the
press he's the deputy head of
counterintelligence and you know what
he's been demoted and reassigned for his
behavior
Iren I want to bring up another point
the the Columbia Law professor to whom
Comey gave that you know those memos two
of the six memos and he basically
instruct him get him out there now he
find out which we didn't know I didn't
know maybe you all knew this that he was
actually a special consultant to the
Justice Department yeah and we now find
out that he's actually now operating as
commis attorneys commis lawyer is that
relevant or does that give him
attorney-client privilege you can't talk
to him about this reloj helps to
understand what Comey was doing in
getting these memos out and this was
actually another stunning revelation not
not only in this interview but also in
his town hall last night which is it
Comey does not consider what he did
leaking he has redefined leaking to mean
a
disclosing classified information and he
believes he has said several times that
he did not leak when he gave this memo
to Dan Richmond for the purpose of
Richmond than telling the New York Times
about it Comey maintains that this was
not a leak he also said it couldn't been
a leak because he had left the FBI and
was no longer
George Stephanopoulos wrote a book about
conversations with Bill Clinton Scott
McClellan wrote a book about
conversations with George W Bush nobody
suggested that those were illegally they
were out of office exactly
and that's precisely the case that Comey
was out of office and he was no more of
a leaker than Stephanopoulos where
McClellan was and nobody R or D
suggested that they were illegal leakers
or liars or should go until last week
the Justice Department kept those Comey
memos as if they were state secrets a
few members of Congress allowed to see
them had to have an FBA at my FBI minder
with them
no notes no copies it's contrary to
Justice Department regulations correct
yeah at least our trade more one on
Capitol Hill believes this was the only
leak Jim Comey did through Daniel
Richmond my guess is there were tons of
that's why he had this special
government employee status s GE status
had the clearance was coming to the FBI
when he wanted to come I'm guessing he
did lots of leaks bring him in and ask
him that well we know there's a tourney
client privilege and bring him in all
right guys phenomenal panel I had no
doubts it would be